this one didn't come this one came from  somebody else uh [ __ ] marry kill chris  the stuff no joe duro's a homeless pimp  so if you don't know these are my uh go  to the no press channel on youtube those  are my podcasts uh chris the stefano joe  deros all right so what has to happen  here is i have to uh marry homeless pen  yeah he has a large skill set he's  younger so i die first which is nice i  don't want to die before my partner and  he has a wonderful smile well you know i  i would i would i would probably uh [ __ ]  christos stefano um  just because he has a very light touch  he has a he has a very light way about  him that really mirrors me so i think  he'd be gentle and then joe derose is  dead and i think that you guys knew that  before you even handed me this card like  you know and then nothing against you  derozan he knew he was dead even when i  got it